I must also mention a big little lies
because that was a tough category
unbelievable I know but I mean I really
feel like that Reese and I won that
together because know she feels that way
but I mean it really is and any owner
will tell you this when you because we
produced it as well and it was so much
work to get it to the screen and then to
have it sort of embraced in the way it
was so it really is ours and also Loras
and Shay liens and and so we I mean the
five of us worked our butts off to get
that thing made and produced and it's
it's been a fantastic journey and we've
got a picture of you at the Emmys there
you are being graduated by Alexander
Skarsgard you are so provocative Graham
why are you showing that it's a lovely
moment of celebration
it looks like Keith is applauding the
kisses good kiss guys well done
everybody did kissing Dan I did
everything with Ali I'm like you know
that's we saw it gorgeous husband who I
love more than anything in the world and
I gave Alex a congratulatory kiss and
he's like a a mannequin yes
[Laughter]
here actually Keith was here with you
and he has been very tight-lipped about
your 50th birthday celebration oh right
so what how do you organize he did some
fireworks and other stuff and we'll draw
a veil there he comes
that's a car so donkey ride blue balloon
marbling
[Music]
you